five days in there still rescuing people
from the clutches of Harvey in Houston
for every person saved like these via
customs police helicopter crew the city
wonders how many weren't it will only be
when these waters recede that they'll
know the police chief says he fears what
the death toll will be it is already a
catastrophe of epic proportions and the
first disaster of Donald Trump's
presidency
he came to Texas to offer his support
and Texas can handle anything
thank you all folks thank you
[Applause]
the biggest concern is to over spilling
reservoirs now pouring water into areas
already flooded you hear a lot about
these neighborhoods affected by the
release of the water from the reservoirs
and this is what that means the water in
those reservoirs feeds the river behind
here and a lake and this is what it's
done to this neighborhood and so the
community rescues continue this couple
and their cat ferried to dry land by a
neighbor and his boat never never and I
will skew it Arvin all over the world
never seen this never seen this and when
you look around was having the rest of
the city is the same thing it's it's all
over the place
so many people are looking for shelter
that Houston's Convention Center has
reached capacity to others have opened
other people being flown elsewhere in
the state they at least survived the
stories of those who didn't are emerging
sergeant steve perez died on a flooded
freeway unfortunately in the darkness
sergeant Perez drove into an underpass
that's about 16 now feet drove into the
water and he died in a flood in a
drowning type event in a story of
remarkable images look at this a photo
taken by Texas politician date feelin on
a road in Beaumont Whitecaps
on the interstate he tweeted there is
now a nighttime curfew in place across
Houston to calm fears of looting the
rain is finally easing that is some
small relief for a city that knows it
may never be the same again
Greg Milam Sky News Houston